[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend ihnen allen jetzt im Warmen
zu Hause sitzen zu können das ist ein
kleines großes Glück
abertausende in der Türkei und in Syrien
stehen vor der dritten Nacht bei eisigen
Temperaturen im Freien Kinder Frauen
Männer weil sie sich nicht mehr in ihre
Häuser trauen weil sie kein Haus mehr
haben
fast 12.000 Leichen sind im
Erdbebengebiet bislang geborgen worden
es werden das ist traurige Gewissheit
noch viele dazu kommen und neben
unendlicher Trauer werden auch Kritik
und Wut lauter Jörg Brase
das Wetter ist gut sie können fliegen
endlich
Helikopter bringen Rettungskräfte auch
in Regionen die bislang unzugänglich
waren und evakuieren von dort die die
überlebt haben
diese deutschen rettungskräfte sind seit
gestern im Einsatz spür Trupps der
Hilfsorganisation Isa mit ihren sieben
Suchhunden konnten Sie bereits einige
verschüttete finden und leben Bergen im
Großen und Ganzen ist ein riesiges Chaos
es ist wirkt ja apokalyptisch weil es
einfach zu groß ist und zu viel wir
versuchen an allen Ecken und Enden was
zu tun kriegen auch immer wieder wir
müssen gar nicht viel suchen immer
wieder kommen Menschen auf uns zu bitten
uns das geholfen wird weil man überall
Stimmen hört doch für andere kommt die
Hilfe zu spät in Hatay werden die
Leichen in einer Sporthalle aufgebaut
draußen werden Lebensmittel verteilt
viel zu lange habe es gedauert bis diese
Hilfe kam so lautet die Kritik auch an
ihm dem Präsidenten Tag drei nach dem
großen Beben
Erdogan besucht Hatay und maßregelt
seine Kritiker
der Solidarität ich kann es nicht
ertragen wenn jemand in einer solchen
Zeit nur auf seinen politischen Vorteil
bedacht ist und simple Schmutzkampagnen
veranstaltet
gemeint sind seine politischen Gegner
wie Oppositionsführer Kemal Kilic daolo
der reiste ebenfalls durch die
Krisenregion und machte Erdogan für die
vielen Toten mitverantwortlich denn 20
Jahre lang habe die Regierung nichts
dafür getan den Erdbeben Schutz zu
verbessern und Experten sehen das
ähnlich solche Bilder dürfte es nicht
geben während Häuser erdbebensicher
gebaut worden doch Korruption und
Ignoranz hätten das verhindert meint der
Geologe
so hätten Kollegen vor einiger Zeit eine
Gefährdungskarte für die Stadt Karaman
Marash gezeichnet
die haben diese Karte an Herrn
Bürgermeister geschickt die
Bürgermeister hat das angeguckt der hat
gesagt das nicht
und nicht gemacht
woher fand diese man diese Autorität zu
sagen dass er das nicht glaubt
noch sind nicht alle Opfer geworden da
droht die Katastrophe zum politischen
Streitfall zu werden im Mai soll in der
Türkei gewählt werden
ein Bild geht heute um die Welt dass
sich ins Gedächtnis brennt
Mesut handchurch sitzt in den Überresten
seines Hauses und hält die Hand seiner
Tochter sie ist tot aber er will sie
nicht loslassen
die Trauer eines verzweifelten Vaters
Anne brüll du hast heute viele solcher
Bilder gesehen wie würdest du deine
Eindrücke von diesem Tag zusammenfassen
ja das Bild dass ich mir heute
eingebrannt hat ist ein einsamer
leichensacker mitten auf der Straße in
elbistan mitten zwischen den Trümmern
unter denen noch so viele Menschen
vermutet werden die offiziellen
Rettungsteams die sind erst heute in
elbistan überhaupt angekommen und es gab
immer wieder diese Momente der völligen
Stille in denen die Retter versucht
haben durchrufe Kontakt zu verschütteten
aufzunehmen aber es blieb einfach immer
nur still was an was ich mich auch
erinnern werde ist die Verzweiflung der
Angehörigen die Menschen die
Überlebenden die schon seit Tagen in
eisiger kälter ausharren und die
natürlich wütend sind wütend darüber
dass die Hilfe in elbistan so sperrt
erst angekommen ist
im Katastrophengebiet ganz herzlichen
Dank für diese Eindrücke so viel
Verzweiflung aber auch für uns hier in
Deutschland die Möglichkeit zu helfen
wenn Sie helfen möchten den Menschen im
Erdbebengebiet dann können Sie das mit
einer Spende beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe und hier ist die
Kontonummer die IBAN dazu
de65100 400 600-100 400 600 das
Stichwort ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien und
Informationen gibt es auch unter Spenden
zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf Seite 890
einen dreiergipfel der besonderen Art
soll es heute Abend in Paris geben
Frankreichs Präsident wird dort zusammen
sitzen mit dem Bundeskanzler und dem
ukraineischen Präsidenten und zwar nicht
wieso oft per Videoschalte sondern in
echt obwohl du mir silenski ist auf
Europa Reise für den Präsidenten eines
Landes das jeden Tag gegen russische
Attacken kämpfen muss kein alltäglicher
Termin aber einer mit viel Symbolik er
war davor in London zu Gast bei
Parlament und König und er will noch
weiter zur EU nach Brüssel Hilke
Petersen
im Süden England wo die britische Armee
ukrainische Soldaten ausbildet Präsident
selenski ist gekommen um den Freunden
wieder und wieder Danke zu sagen
Challenger 2 Panzer Stolz des britischen
Militärs der Großbritannien bald in die
Ukraine liefern
und Downing Street bietet mehr
Großbritannien wird jetzt sogar
ukrainische Kampfpiloten ausbilden damit
die in Zukunft auch natojets fliegen
könnten lange umstritten
in Westminster Hall ist das Ganze
Parlament versammelt
für eine emotionale silensky-rede
from
von den ersten Sekunden und Minuten des
Krieges an habt ihr Großbritannien eure
helfende Hand gereicht während die Welt
noch nicht begriffen hatte was sie tun
sollte
der echte Pilotenhelm als Geschenk
sollte lenskis oft gehörter Forderung
nach Kampfjets von den Verbündeten noch
mehr Kraft verleihen das britische
Verteidigungsministerium prüft
inzwischen ob Jets verfügbar sind
danke an alle im voraus für kraftvolle
englische Flugzeuge
am Nachmittag im Buckingham Palast König
Charles sei ja ein Air Force Pilot sagt
selenski zuvor daheim in der Ukraine sei
jeder Kampfpilot ein König
am Ende des Tages Paris hier sind der
französische Präsident und Kanzler
Scholz mit selenski verabredet was er
ihnen sagen wird danke für Unterstützung
und dass ein Land Kampfjets braucht um
Russland zu besiegen Druck auf Freunde
ja und morgen will der ukrainische
Präsident dann also beim EU-Gipfel mit
dabei sein auf dessen eigentliche Themen
hat der Bundeskanzler heute bereits
geguckt und Hannah du hast mehr dazu ja
am mit hat Bundeskanzler Scholz eine
Regierungserklärung zum morgigen
EU-Sondergipfel gehalten eines der
Hauptthemen dabei die Herausforderungen
durch die Migration in seiner Rede vor
dem Bundestag zeigte sich Scholz
zuversichtlich dass eine Reform des
europäischen Asylsystems bis Mitte 2024
möglich sei zudem stellte er sich hinter
den von Innenministerin Phaser
einberufenen flüchtlingsgipfel mit
Ländern und Kommunen und wir uns
Fraktionschef März forderte hingegen
einen Gipfel unter der Führung des
Kanzlers selbst
in seiner Rede zur Lage der Nation hat
US-Präsident beiden angekündigt die
heimische Wirtschaft weiter stärken zu
wollen so soll künftig auch bei
Baumaterialien für Infrastrukturprojekte
das Prinzip made in Amerika gelten die
Republikaner rief beiden mit Blick auf
die neuen Mehrheitsverhältnisse im
Kongress so Zusammenarbeit auch außerdem
sagte der US-Präsident der Ukraine
Unterstützung zu solange dies nötig sein
laut internationalen Ermittlern gibt es
Hinweise dafür dass der russische
Präsident Putin eine Rolle beim Abschuss
des Passagierflugzeugs mh17 über der
Ostukraine im Jahr 2014 gespielt hat es
gäbe starke Anzeichen dass Putin
persönlich entschieden habe die
verwendete bodenluftrakete an die
Separatisten zu liefern erklärten die
Ermittler in Den Haag dabei stützen sie
sich auf abgehörte Telefongespräche für
eine strafrechtliche Verfolgung würden
die Beweise nicht ausreichen
und jetzt die Lottozahlen die lauten 8
14 17 21 39 44 Superzahl 9 alle Angaben
wie immer ohne Gewähr
fehlen noch die Wetteraussichten morgen
im Nordwesten zunehmend bewölkt aber nur
vereinzelt etwas Regen sonst wieder viel
Sonne bei Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 0
und 7 Grad in den nächsten Tagen im
Norden viele Wolken und etwas Regen im
Süden freundlich Freitag 0 bis 8 Grad am
Wochenende wieder Bilder
und so viel von uns in Kurzform wir
danken fürs Interesse und sagen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]